Sallu asks you not including your
investments which five startups IPOs are
you most excited for yet startup IPOs
that you are excited for I think
draftkings is gonna be super interesting
in the sense that that whole space
around sports to include eSports etc is
gonna be really big weight um yeah I
think that'll be big especially if they
can crack into like financial betting
right you start getting into all that
kind of stuff I think will be
interesting prop that's right like what
do they call those trading markets they
call them
I mean imagine when they start betting
I'm like how long is Jim Cramer's you
know monologue gonna be at the start of
you know whatever yeah any show yeah
like when the press or who's gonna be
President of the United States right who
will be vice president absolutely
yeah those prop bets are really
interesting so I think that space is
interesting definitely the cannabis
space I think is still very very under
appreciated by a lot of people I don't
just have an individual company they're
a company that I think actually doesn't
get enough love in the United States
we're investors so I'm definitely biased
is Robin Hood or not Robin Hood is Robin
Hood competitor eToro
yeah in Europe and so for everything I
know
eToro is actually bigger business but
much lower valuation and so they've just
done it in Europe Robin Hood's in
America and now they're trying to like
switch places right where each or
shouldn't come to the u.s. from who's
trying to go international so this give
me like the lift
kind of competition or yeah yeah but but
it's interesting because uber lyft both
started in San Francisco and then went
through global domination at the same
time right two different strategies but
but so same type of rollouts sounds good
merge yeah and and create it they could
merge it and also they there's a
question of uber and lyft you could put
both on your phone and just see who's
the cheapest who has the fastest car to
get to you yeah I don't think you do
that with a brokerage account no that's
a little hard yeah and Nora is right I
mean these things are
it's I think it's an Android not an or
two like you might have Netflix and
Disney if you see value in both of the
platforms they do something slightly
different unless they're not commoditize
and they have the same offering you
might have two right I could see people
as people as the gamification of Finance
continues and people have what is it
coinbase is the big you know app for
crypto trading yeah you'd have like
coinbase well front Robinhood eToro you
might have like six or seven of these
apps eventually and you know you might
have Bank of America or Morgan Stanley
some old ones that have these janky apps
but you know I think that they're gonna
have these like super refined set and
people might just bounce between them